so Abby grossberg okay Abby grossberg uh
uh who
um she works at Fox she was working
under Tucker I think at one point she
was their senior Booker I don't think
her and Tucker have ever met she
criticizes Tucker what the environment's
like they don't care about telling the
truth and they don't care about woman
this is what she said of Fox News all
they care about is ratings and revenue
right that's her now the exchange came
about where your uh Ari melber I think
eight days ago this you've been on Ari
multiple you guys have had some good
exchanges together and he shares a
recording and here's what he says I want
to get your thoughts on this so so
recording February 27 2021 you say Trump
also has to clean up the people who
surrounded him in the final days of
administration and who are crowding him
now at Mar-A-Lago uh like tens of
millions of dollars left in the campaign
that they didn't spend in time to
challenge the election issues and oh
that was criminal Abby grossberg says
what happened to all that money Navarro
well not there now they're going to I'm
going to name names
Bill State stadium
Justin Clark are the campaign guys now
that they'll go on the payroll and
they'll spend that money and it'll go
right into their pockets Brad parskill
uh might get some of that as well it's
crazy so one thing we're learning about
Abby if you're ever talking to her just
assume there's a recording if she's
recording the conversation okay but what
happened yeah
because I I as much as I like Abby and I
I interacted with her only when she was
part of Romo's producer before she got
with Tucker is she trusted is she good
at what the idea she's very good at what
she does
um and and I can talk a lot about how
the problem at Fox but let me just say
that she had no business recording me
that that without telling me that that's
yeah I I and by the way I don't mind
yeah when I say something
I consider it to be on the record okay
these reporters say well you wanna do
background no no no it's like here it is
I'm just I'll tell you that but um I
think what's interesting about Abby
grossberg and my interactions with her
um as a frequent guest on bartiromo's
Sunday show was was kind of the the
progression of my cancellation from Fox
you know when I first got out of the
White House I I would go on Bartiromo
show like I did when I was in the white
house it was like like no big deal but
but what what would happen afterwards
it's like
Abby would put me in Maria would want me
on and some other producer somewhere who
should have had no business intervening
would say now he can't do that or he
can't talk about this there was one case
and this is breaking a little news where
I actually recorded a segment I think it
was on fauci
um and it was I mean if you play that
today it was like Fidelity I mean it was
just so spot on but for whatever reason
it was too hot to handle they canceled
it they took it out of the lineup and
they did it at such a late date because
they they taped the show and then they
put it together just before air time
that they had like a gap kind of at the
end from it
um but what that tells me is that that
the sensors at Fox were the never Trump
wing of the Fox News Network which is
which is large and larger now was
already beginning to work their magic
and Abby was was caught in that because
she was trying to do
legitimate
hard-hitting news that would appeal to
the fox viewer
and she wasn't being allowed to do that
I don't know what happened with the
Tucker stuff I I love Tucker I don't
want to get in the middle of that but I
do know when she was working for
Bartiromo the Fox News producers
with orders from uh the second floor
that's what they'd always say it was
from the second floor who's that that's
Suzanne Scott who runs the network in
Lauren he's a powerful person in media
Suzanne Scott and Lauren Patterson don't
don't count her out she is uh
she is uh more of a snake than Suzanne
is Suzanne's Suzanne will tell you to
your face Lauren will just stab you in
the back so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]